the european union has defended its
vaccine procurement strategy saying it
is not unravelling
frustrated by the pace of the vaccine
rollout some eu countries are buying
doses of jabs from china
and russia which are not currently
abused approved for use in europe and
austria and denmark have broken ranks to
form an alliance with israel to produce
second generation vaccines to combat
mutations of the virus
well joining me now is guna beck a
german mep and a member of the uk
coordination group in the european
parliament
hello to you at gunner beck at the
european union defending its vaccine
strategy denying that it is
unraveling but what does it look like
there
well uh good afternoon to you um
it doesn't look very good here i'll give
you one simple example
uh about one third of the uk
population has been vaccinated now
in germany for example that figure
currently
stands at about seven percent of the
population um in the uk
practically everyone over 80 and i
suspect the vast majority
of those over 70 have now been
uh have now received their first dose
that is not the case in germany
it's not only about problems with
the european wide rollout though is it
there is also a vaccine hesitancy there
are doses
in germany available for people to have
the vaccine but 85
of supplies of the astrazeneca vaccine
are sitting
unused uh i think that's right well i
think there are two aspects here which
we have to
uh distinguish there's a great deal more
skepticism of vaccination in general
both in germany as well as another uh
as well as a number of other continental
countries including france for example
and i'd like to stress i'm not uh
expressing any view
on the appropriateness of vaccination
as a treatment for coronary virus and
then there's a second
aspect namely that there's a
very limited take up of the astrazeneca
vaccine in germany and i um
dare to claim that this is in large
measure
due to a barrage of
adverse propaganda from the chancellor
down about
about that vaccine which has since been
largely refuted
yeah and we had data published last
night here in the uk
about the efficacy of the oxford
astrozenica vaccine and the fires of
vaccines in the over 70s the group which
countries like germany
didn't want to give the vaccine to what
needs to be done now there are some
calls that angela merkel
should take the vaccine herself be seen
to be having the vaccine to try and
assure the population that it is safe
well uh she's announced that uh
the vax well initially she expressed uh
skepticism about the
british vaccine then she announced she
wasn't going to take it herself
then she's tried to reassure the
population about
the quality of the british vaccine well
many of those claims she and others made
about the british vaccine
have proved to be unfounded to the
extent to which men's could be made
and the situation be rectified i think
your suggestion is a fair one
um she could attend best if she herself
volunteered to take the british
vaccine and from all we know should take
no
additional risks as a result uh emmanuel
macron who of course had described the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine as
quasi-ineffective for the over 65s now
that's been proven to be incorrect he's
now said he'd have the oxford vaccine
but is it is it too late is the damage
done
well i think it's very difficult to
rectify now
but i think that's just one uh part of
the
uh eu failure the truth is of course
that uh the eu is short of uh vaccines
generally that explains why it's lagging
far behind
the british in terms of the vaccination
rate and that's a reflection of the fact
that whereas britain took a
calculated gamble in backing
a company that from the word go almost
was amongst those those
corporations uh to come out early with a
vaccine
the eu for uh lots of
internal reasons and lobbying and the
like
decided uh to split
the contracts between six or seven
manufacturers
one of them a french company will only
be
able to deliver at the end of the year
at the earliest